quanti morti quanti morti
no fermi fermi l'epicità sofia viscardi
la cosa ma perché si chiama sofia
viscardi quei facciamo amici e benvenuti
a questo nuovo episodio di della
melevisione siamo su slitte rio allora
l'ultimo episodio è stata una bomba
perché va bene lo speciale decimo
episodio quindi ho messo tutti gli
highlights roba che ancora non ho visto
ho dato che dà un sacco che non faccio
un episodio di slitte rio decente è
esattamente questo non l'ho visto le
ultime skin di slither io perché non ci
ho fatto proprio caso non ho più
guardato bella apri break si fa tra
l'altro non ho la moda attivata la fan
cuore va beh perché in genere ciò la
moda quella che mi zuma invece mi sono
dimenticato di attivarla veda in all
attivo provo senza in culo
sono forte a ragazzi e va bene stai
calmo calmati caffè non ho ancora capito
oddio cosa ho fatto mai velocissimo
fatto ti devi morire la famiglia non
fatta ma basta scherzavo mettiamo la
cosa dello zoom perché oggi siamo sipro
fammi giocare non me ne frega niente di
tutte le novità che c'hai mara questo
era questa la moto non so se va bene ha
ucciso prima è rimasto qui due punti ci
credo ce l'ho fatta vabbè ma piano piano
non secolo come l'attuale va bè non è
morto nessuno
ma dai macro avis ore si sono schiantati
in due non è morto neanche uno
fantastico grande eva bel lag madonna
che la chiesa succede perché laga così
tanto dai dai dai dai dai trader madonna
che la ga assurdo eh vabbè l'effetto
perfetto vai vai laga lo schifo non so
perché madonna contibuti ho preso un
voto 6 scarso non è morto va bene quanta
roba c'è no ragazzi ci sono talmente
tanti punti che larga se vi rendete
conto sta allagando svizzeri io un gioco
di merda come fa la gare slitherine
talmente tanti punti da mandare in crash
il gioco sul serio avere che non ci sto
credendo quanti punti ho preso in
crediti
quanto sono grosso e vabbè basta quanta
roba
la ragazza è ingiocabile così vi giuro
solo se tutti un colleghi quanto sono
grosso solo nono in un secondo sono
arrivato nono se succede un'altra volta
una roba del genere l'arrivo
praticamente primo so che non succederà
mai più è già una botta di culo
incredibile
l'aida [ __ ] non stavo guardando non
ci credo mai nel maine sa mai nella vita
non ci posso credere mai non stavo
guardando il davanti guardavo gli altri
sono un genio lama doc incula nola
bergamo oggi grazie ma dopo quasi tre di
fila ma do ragazzi di proviamoci senza
modo voglio solo capire lago
vediamo se mi lascia senza che bordello
che cosa se cosa come come mi sono
salvato come ho fatto a salvarmi
possibile no comunque mi sa che era la
moda gare grazie quanti morti morti
no fermi fermi l'epicità l'epicità di
questa scena cosa è successo cosa ecco
come va bè è se riuscissi a uccidere
pure lui maledizione nuova dei ragazzi
l'epicità dista scena incredibile cosa è
successo perfetto perfetto perfetto
perfetto spam grazie
allora ci riprova ragazzino seriamente
sono riuscito in sei partite sto facendo
i culi non lo so perché poi mi schianto
come un idiota e tutte e due le volte mi
sono schiantati come un idiota prova per
questo va bè sosta 64.000 se sponsorizza
instagram a che cazzo ne sponsorizza che
si sa può mica se perdo per colpa tua
vado acciaccati instagram guarda pon
grandissimo succhiami la milza spiega mi
costa fatica e ti ritrovi che cacciari e
della tizia questa puntata e stranissima
perché sto facendo cose epiche ma epiche
e allo stesso tempo poi muoio come un
rincoglionito quindi di tutto e di più
ti uccido ma ragazzi sono veramente un
fuori co
madonna fatti la camomilla che problemi
33 è morto visse di aiuto qualcuno che è
qui e devo fare i ragazzi se non li
faccio fuori io sto gioco noi fa fuori
nessuno che fastidio tutto io devo fare
tutti io con i più grossi li devo
uccidere io sto vicino sti qua prima o
poi crepar a qualcuno l'ho ucciso io
perché se non li uccide nessuno ad o
fare tutto io eh ma valuta tutti in
punti mi hanno [ __ ] tutti i punti
porca [ __ ] ladra laida tutti i punti
ne hanno [ __ ] basta mi stavo
schiantando di nuovo come l'idiota devo
stare attento quando faccio le cose
epiche che un secontip un secondo dopo
il rischio di morire
ok puoi togliere dalla mia vita grazie
perfetto quanta gente grossa qualcuno
che muoia dai non muore nessuno polacchi
alla polacchi a oggi no non è vero non è
vero non è vero non è vero ma quando che
l'ho preso io dai raga ma tu come si è
schiantato male come lo [ __ ] baraka
gare sta uccidendo volo gigante
maledizione ma c'è la guerra aperta così
è morto mi fanno tutti tutti io sono più
figo come gli oil curati tutti quanto
sto quanto sto 2600 dai madonna come sto
morendo
quanto siete grossi li potete uccidere
per favore qualcuno lo può uccidere
questo capita in culo tedesco ma non amo
lo schiaccio lo schiaccio questo lo
schiaccio lo schiaccio suga madonna che
tattica questo quello appena inventata
adesso ragazzi di qualcuno si infila tra
di voi è un altro verme stringete lo il
più possibile tanto si si si si ammazza
per forza è morto quello che mi stava in
culo vai vai vai veloce madonna con il
suo salvato ma vabbè non ci credo per
una volta nella vita mi sono salvato dai
va beh
ecco questo ho usato la mia tattica ecco
perfetto magari questa tattica usate la
quando non ci sono io in partita va bene
l'ho spiegata un secondo fa l'ha usata
adesso già visto il video lui ha già
capito tutto
ma stai quell'uomo ha passato la vita su
slitte rio per sfamarsi lista gramsci e
rendetevi conto sia io che grosso che il
tuo serpente si opera del dottor culo
cane dai sì o famigliari così capace se
il verme grosso è per me grosso più
grosso senti verme grosso potresti farmi
fa mannaggia sio perché mi fai questo si
è appreso fossimo amici ho provato anche
il tuo gioco allora per ripicca io mi
chiamo così come l'ho ucciso la cia i
primi punti per i punti da huck
grandissimo le culo a merda non era
abbastanza lungo
questi sono i problemi dei maschi di
oggi l'ho ucciso io davvero ma non ci
crederà mi sarà in culo ragazzo era una
questione tra me e lui lui neanche lo
sapeva vedi che il nome di ceo porta
fortuna grazie sia piante la sistina
terapia viscardi ma cosa ma perché si
chiama sofia viscardi questo milan blue
chip è morta a sofia viscardi non è vero
non è un gossip ma ho preso i punti di
sofia viscardi sono primo io ho
risucchiato gli iscritti o che avrebbe
detto eva bene quanti punti un secondo
solo grazie sofia grazie sofia viscardi
qualcuno deve spiegare questa scena
perché non l'ho capita neanch'io però va
bene titolo alternativo per questo video
diventare primo su slitte rio uccidendo
su sofia viscardi melo sori globe ato
male in teoria sarei dovuto morire io
qua è però questo gioco funziona come
cazzo vuole lui di inglobare tutti è
però non c'ho voglia odio grazie fatto
morire così ma [ __ ] regala vi giuro
ci ho provato in tutti i modi a sterzare
male
colpa di sofia viscardi pa pa pa gaza
gag complimenti per l'impegno nel
scegliere il nome per quanto è grosso
questo è quello di prima e papà ragazze
papa lo uccido io che sono tutto grosso
è forte non si disturba serpente mentre
andava bene grazie questo si è
schiantato a caso io sono fiducioso del
fatto eco lo gigante morirà non lo so
perché ce lo so sto dubbio 3 morta gente
quindi tutti i punti no grazie su kakà è
e mi spiace ci sta che nel mentre quello
sì ingloba l'altro io divento più grosso
di lui elin globo tutti e due
la farò mai nella vita perché dovevo
diventare quinti in classifica per
inglobare quello lì però va bene grazie
però le premesse sono molto buone a
quanto vedo è morto è morto
posso farlo possono farlo scrivendo ci
provo
ci provo ci provo non ci credo no
c'erano così fatta veramente cazzola mo
così globe non ci credo
l'avevo quasi inglobato non so come ho
fatto devi morire male papara faccia
gagaville ma va che cazzo non ho parole
per descrivere questo questa punta nata
la madoff e kill puoi stare calmo zio
grazie è perfetto
ti dovresti togliere io non ho parole
direttamente sono veramente io non so
non so veramente cosa non lo so non so
cosa dire sono esterrefatto da questa
come cazzo ho fatto a morire io 600
volte nello stesso modo con un pirla
tutte le volte non c'è verso di esistere
eva la sei stronzo ai ora primo così i
ragazzi mi chiamo grettamente arrivò
primo solco vinto un grandissimo no no
no no no fatti i cazzi tuoi
devi farti capito